معنا من رام الله اللواء الركن المتقاعد
واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه لواء عريقات اهلا
بك كل هذا الدعم الامريكي والامدادات
العسكريه الامريكيه التي وصلت الى اسرائيل
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب ولم يستطع الجيش
الاسرائيلي تقديم صوره انجاز واحد في هذه
الحرب
لماذا بالتاكيد لان هناك شعب عظيم صابر
وصامد على الالم وما زال يحتضن المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهناك حاضنه شعبيه
اسرائيليه معنوياتها متدنيه في الحضيض
الحرب الان بين المقاومين الفلسطينيين
والجنود الاسرائيليين هي حرب ايرادات حرب
معنويات حينما نقول لليوم
الثين ما زالت المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه يشتبك برشاش ويقصف
بمدفع وبصاره وينصب الكمائن ويفخر الانفاق
يفجر الدبابات ويقتنص عن مسافه صفر انا
بتقديري هذا يعني هذه معارك تدرس في ارقى
الاكاديميات العسكريه كيف لهذا المقاوم
وبعد كل هذه الايام من القصف التدميري
بالطائرات ومدفعيه بريه وبحريه وسياسه
الارض المحروقه وحرب الاباده الجماعيه وما
زال يخرج من تحت الانقاض ويشتبك مع الجنود
الاسرائيليين ويوقع فيهم خسائر كثيره انا
بتقديري يعني هناك اسئله كثيره الان ستدرس
في الاكاديميات الع العسكريه كيف قتلوا
هؤلاء الجنود الاسرائيليين ومن قتلهم وما
هو السلاح الذي قتلوا فيه وما هي الحاله
النفسيه التي كان كان يتمتع بها المقاوم
الفلسطيني مقابل المعنويات المتدنيه عند
الجنود الاسرائيليين مقارنه بالخسائر التي
لحقت بالجيش الاسرائيلي في قتاله مع
الجيوش الاخرى يعني الوقت يعني نتحدث عن
80 يوم وهناك معارك لم تخوضها اسرائيل سوى
ايام قليله
وفي مواجهه جيوش كبيره ولديها امكانيات
هائله طبيعه الارض الارض الان التي حاولت
اسرائيل ان تسخرها لصالحها الارض الان
تقاتل مع اهلها تقاتل مع المقاتلين لاحظي
اختي العزيزه كل كل العمليات الناجحه تخرج
من تحت الانقاض من تحت المباني المدمره من
من من الدماء من الدموع التي سالت في هذه
الابنيه ومع كل ذلك البطولات تخرج من تحت
هذه الابنيه وهذه ال وانا اعتقد انه هناك
الم كبير الان اي في الداخل الاسرائيلي
كما هو الالم عند الفلسطينيين من عدد
الشهداء وهذه الدماء البريئه التي تسال
نحن نتحدث الان عن جبهتين ايضا الجبهه
الداخليه الفلسطينيه والجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه لهما اكبر التاثير يعني حينما
يخرج الفلسطيني من تحت الانقاظ وهو فاقد
لكل اسرته وافراد عائلته ويتحدث عن الصمود
ويتحدث عن الانتصار وهزيمه الجيش
الاسرائيلي في مقابل المظاهرات التي تخرج
في داخل فلسطين المحتله تطلب من الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يتوقف عن قتل جنوده وابنائه
هذه انا بتقديري يعني حرب ربما لم تحدث في
تاريخ الحروب العسكريه في القرن الحديث
ولانها كذلك لواء عريقات ما هي تلك
المفاهيم العسكريه التي بدلتها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في هذه الحرب على صعيد مقاومات
الحروب و كذلك اعاده صياغه ربما
وتشكيل ما نفهمه ونعرفه عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعني اعتقد انه اول اول عنصر
يجب ان يعرفه العالم حول هذه الحروب بان
المعنويات هي الاساس السلاح لا يقاتل
الدبابه لا تقاتل الطائره لا تقاتل المدفع
لا يقاتل الذي يقاتل هو من يحمل السلاح
فبالتالي حينما يكون هناك انتماء حينما
يكون هنا و ولاء للارض وللوطن وهناك عقيده
قتاليه وهناك روح معنويه وهناك حاضنه
شعبيه تؤمن بانها ستنتصر انا بتقديري هذا
سيكون حليف المقاتل في في كل معاركه اضافه
الى انه يعني ما ما يجري على ارض الواقع
من تكتيكات عسكريه ودروس وفنون حرب اي
تدرس في الاكاديميات العسكريه اعتقد انه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الان في استخدامه
لطبيعه الارض وفي استخدامه وبعد مرور
الوقت الطويل
وحجم وحجم الالم الذي الم بالشعب
الفلسطيني كحضن شعبيه وحجم القصف الذي
تعرض له المقاوم وحجم الضغوطات التي
يعيشها المقاوم بين الانقاظ ويخرج من تحت
هذه الانقاض ويقاتل ببساله وبشجاعة
وبثبات وقدره على التنسيق والتعاون
والمحافظه على على على سلوكه الاخلاقي
ايضا لانه نحن نلاحظ ان الجندي الاسرائيلي
يقتل يقتل بالدبابه يقتل بالطائره يقتل
بالمدفع في حين ان المقاتل الفلسطيني
يقاتل الجنود هو حافظ على المدنيين وما
زال حتى حتى الاسرى الموجودين عند
المقاومين الفلسطينيين يعاملهم معامله كما
يعامل ابنائه فبالتالي يعني هناك ايضا
يعني دروس في الاخلاق وفي القيم اثناء
الحروب هناك دروس في الانسانيه هناك دروس
في الحرب النفسيه والاعلاميه وحرب
الاشاعات هذه كلها اعتقد ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه برز فيها في مقابل اخفاقات في
الجانب الاسرائيلي شكرا لك اللواء الركن
المتقاعد واصف عرقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه من رام الله